you love The Exorcist when you were
growing up when you were a kid dreaming
about being a filmmaker you wrote a
letter to the makeup artist Dick Smith
Dick Smith did all the makeup on The
Exorcist which was an incredible uh
makeup job right unbelievable so you
write him a letter and he sent you a
tongue yeah a tongue yeah from the movie
The Exorcist that's right yeah I got
Dick Smith was someone who he did you
know uh Godfather he did Altered States
scanners uh but and The Exorcist So I
sent this fan letter and I was you know
13 years old and I received in the mail
this little box I still have it and it
says Dick Smith Larchmont New York and I
open the thing up there's a little
handwritten note and there's a foam
latex tongue wow and he says here's a an
old but clean tongue from The Exorcist
you know put a little peanut butter in
it and stick it in it and I'm like holy
crap so I start this correspondence with
him ask him all these questions this is
before they were behind the scenes
featurettes and also you couldn't
download information so right he told
every secret he was so generous and and
it turns out uh that I was among a 100
or plus uh fans who would send him
constantly send him letters and he would
respond to each of us he introduced me
to Guillermo del Toro in 1990. Guillermo
del Toro go great director who also was
you know he was this you know upcoming
Mexican director who sent this the same
kind of notes to dick and dick would
respond and he was just the most uh uh
generous uh incredibly generous guys
send a 13 year old a tongue from The
Exorcist but he would he would answer I
mean dozens of letters I mean we it was
like getting a master course filmmaking
and one day this was so crazy I was I
think I was 15 or 16 I was in uh at
LaGuardia I was my mom and I went to
pick up my father who was flying in and
I see a man come off the plane and I'm
thinking holy crap that's I think that's
Dick Smith I never met him before and he
had four fingers on his left hand
because at one point he was working on a
job and he jumped off a train and his
ring got caught and it basically
stripped his finger so we had the bone
cut off right so look at him he only had
four fingers on his left hand and I was
like a it's a Hitchcock movie I'm like
watching this man and thinking if he has
four fingers that's him that's Dick
Smith yeah and he had four fingers and I
go up to him and this is like he to me
is like the Rolling Stones he's like the
Beatles I'm like holy no one cares right
and I guess I'm like Mr Smith and he's
like and he was the sweetest guy and I
actually got to work with him years
later on a on a movie
Forever Young yeah yeah you worked with
him on that yeah he did the old day age
makeup with Greg Cannon for on Mel
Gibson you hired him because uh you know
Smith he was actually in retirement and
we actually got him out of retirement to
work on that and you were 13 and didn't
your mom say who's this dick who's uh my
mom said who's this man named dick and
why does he keep sending you tongues
maybe something weird is going on yeah
with our kids I think if a guy if a
stranger started sending my kids a
tongue in the mail I'd be very confused